>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> BARD Express: Browsing
the Recently Added
and Most Popular Lists.
>> Judy: Hi, I'm Judy Dixon,
Consumer Relations Officer at NLS.
In this edition of the
BARD Express How-To Series,
I'm going to cover browsing
the BARD most popular
and recently added lists.
To browse the recently added
list, select Recently Added Books
and Magazines from the
BARD Express Main Menu.
You will be presented with a
list of books and magazines added
to BARD in the last 10 days.
If you want to display materials
added in the last 30 days, 45 days,
or 1 day, tab to the
time range combo box
and select the desired time.
You can also narrow your results
by using the subject filter.
In this example I am going to
uncheck all available subjects
and check the boxes associated
with Adventure and Bestsellers.
>> NVDA: Loading Recently Added
Books and Magazines Page 1.
Loaded Recently Added Books
and Magazines items 1 to 45.
Numbered account.
Author Reich, Christopher.
1 of 45.
>> Judy: Tab to access
the list of titles
and use the arrow keys
to browse the results.
From this screen you can add
titles to your wish list,
download them, or access
their details.
Additionally, you may change
the sort order of the book list.
If you are going to download
or add to your wish list more
than one title from this list, I
recommend you use the advanced view.
Switch to the advanced view using
the keyboard shortcut control L.
Then select the titles you wish
to download using the spacebar.
In this example, we are
going to download three books
and add three books
to our wish list.
>> NVDA: Numbered account
check box selected not checked.
Author Reich, Christopher.
Subject Adventure.
Narrator James DeLotel.
Reading Time 22 hours, 1 minute.
Checked. A wild justice: a novel
check box selected not checked.
Author Thomas, Craig.
Subject Adventure.
Narrator Ken Kliban.
Reading Time 13 hours, 29 minutes.
Checked. Gentlemen of adventure
check box selected not checked.
Author Gann, Ernest Kellogg.
Subject Adventure.
Narrator Fred Major.
Reading Time 17 hours, 45 minutes.
Checked. Add to wish list button,
alt + w. Download button,
alt + d. Unavailable.
There are now 3 items downloading.
Multi-line.
[download status beeps]
Recently Added Books and Magazines.
Press F1 for help list.
Gentlemen of adventure check
box selected not checked.
Author Gann, Ernest Kellogg.
Subject Adventure.
Narrator Fred Major.
Reading Time 17 hours, 45 minutes.
Downloads are complete.
>> Judy: Once your downloads are
complete your books will be stored
on your BARD Express bookshelf
until you are ready to transfer them
to a cartridge and the focus
will return to the list.
We will add three titles to our
wish list by checking the boxes
and activating the Add
to Wish List button.
>> NVDA: Ronia, the robber's
daughter check box selected
not checked.
Author Lindgren, Astrid.
Subject Historical
Fiction/Adventure.
Narrator Louise Beddow.
Reading Time 5 hours, 34 minutes.
Checked. The hidden oracle
check box selected not checked.
Author Riordan, Rick/Daymond,
Robbie.
Subject Adventure/Fantasy Fiction.
Narrator Robbie Daymond.
Reading Time 10 hour, 36 minutes.
Checked. Las aventuras de
Huckleberry Finn check box selected
not checked.
Author Twain, Mark.
Subject Adventure/Spanish Language.
Narrator Juan Wolf.
Reading Time 6 hours, 54 minutes.
Checked. Add to wish list button,
alt+ w. Three items
added to wish list.
Multi-line.
>> Judy: In addition to
browsing the recently added books
and magazines list you may also
browse the most popular BARD books
by going back to the main menu
and selecting the Most
popular books button.
>> NVDA: Recently added books
and magazines, control R button.
Most Popular Books,
control d button.
Loading Most Popular Books.
Most Popular books.
15th affair check box
selected not checked.
Author Patterson, James/Paetro,
Maxine.
Subject Suspense Fiction/Mystery
and Detective Stories.
Narrator January LaVoy.
Reading Time 7 hours, 24 minutes.
>> Judy: Use the arrow up and
down keys to browse the list.
When you find a title you want to
download or add to your wish list,
use the space bar to check the box
and tab to the appropriate button.
If you find a title in the list
that you want to hear more about,
check the box and tab to
the book details button.
>> NVDA: Title 15th Affair.
Patterson, James text.
Patterson, James link.
Paetro, Maxine text.
Paetro, Maxine link.
Subject Suspense Fiction.
Subject Mystery and
Detective Stories.
Annotation: Detective
Lindsay Boxer's life unravels
when a mysterious blonde woman
with links to the CIA disappears
from the scene of a
brutal hotel murder,
a plane crash plunges
San Francisco into chaos,
and Lindsay's husband Joe vanishes.
Lindsay suspects that Joe
and the blonde are linked.
Unrated. Commercial audiobook.
2016. Multi-line.
>> Judy: From this screen
you can download the title
or add it to your wish list.
Use the Back to Most Popular Books
button to return to the list.
For more information on
transferring books, searching BARD,
and managing your wish list see
the other tutorials in this series.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.